bouncing my area the only two teams left
which is one can hold long we're talking
about right there just casually knocks
down the jump
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
taking on Toronto who they just saw
Christmas Day
Tatom
it returns it over
[Applause]
just a Thompson will defend his side
Tatum gets in a plate
[Applause]
as his team was into jams if you haven't
been following man playing their best
basketball of the year right take them
on this one
and watch the little pic there by ice
that keeps the low shot blocker defender
we didn't get a chance to see if Romeo
Langford who is kind of wonder what the
attraction was we'll certainly see the
attraction
[Applause]
Cavs have missed six free throws already
nice game
negative knocks down a three Walker just
too good amazing David once again gets
Nance step-back three
[Applause]
take the varsity playing with the JV
here damn spins the opposite way
[Music]
try again
seriously this case sounds like smart
basketball players and guys out there
who are making the right place for each
other we all want to win and we have the
same goal in mind stuff like that front
end of the sound watch seed leaf if you
can see it he was over the top of the
rim lumps are shy
[Applause]
Brown is not really that develop these
handles
Satan powers it in and a chance for a
three-point play
huh they're taking advantage in this
match here
watch his smooth move itay Tatum has
grown up by leaps and bounds
26 he County potatoes will be back
I think it's Sexton guitars here comes
brown
[Music]
to the basket Cantor loved Efendi
[Music]
[Applause]
blowing fire Tina
tees it up again this one goes down
Walker trying to squeeze it up somehow
gets the offensive rebound is trapped in
the corner round two three threes now
darling
[Music]
big time rebounded traffic by Thompson
but then I was taken away
[Applause]
look out
[Applause]
gets it back and flushes it
Gribbs on the Miss but it doesn't miss
that one whoa takes it Walker
[Applause]
[Music]
that's the rebound and Jalen was at the
top of the defense and nobody near him
and he just took off it great
recognition what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content